>> Will Sentance: Bây giờ, chúng tôi đang đi đến đoạn cuối cùng, gần như.
Vì vậy, ở đây, chúng tôi đã có nó, chúng tôi đã có những chia sẻ tuyệt vời của mình,
phiên bản lưu duy nhất của chức năng và các đối tượng của chúng tôi.
Người dùng 1, người dùng 2, người dùng 500 [SOUND] đều có quyền truy cập vào nó thông qua chuỗi proto.
Không, thông qua tham chiếu proto, do bản chất nguyên mẫu JavaScript,
tính năng nguyên mẫu của nó, khả năng cho các đối tượng kết nối với các đối tượng khác.
Vì vậy, khi chúng ta không tìm thấy một hàm trên đối tượng đã cho, đừng hoảng sợ, hãy tiếp tục.
Được rồi, bây giờ, tôi muốn làm điều gì đó thú vị ở đây, không có tiền thưởng.
Điều gì xảy ra nếu tôi muốn xác nhận, không có gì thay đổi bằng cách này, ngoại trừ
bây giờ tôi không sử dụng gia số.
Tôi đang sử dụng phương pháp này, hàm này hasOwnProperty.
Điều gì sẽ xảy ra nếu chúng tôi muốn xác nhận user1 của chúng tôi có điểm thuộc tính?
Điều này thật thú vị, hasOwnProperty ở đây.
Tôi cho rằng hasOwnProperty có trên user1 như một thuộc tính, Matt, phải không?
>> Người nói 2: Vâng, ý tôi là, không có gì ở đó cả.
>> Will Sentance: Không có tài sản, xin lỗi,
không có phương thức nào được gọi là hasOwnProperty, vâng, chính xác.
Nó phải có trên cửa hàng chức năng người dùng, phải không Todd?
>> Người nói 2: Không, không phải.
>> Will Sentance: Vậy chức năng này sẽ đến từ đâu?
Hóa ra mọi người thấy rằng có một đối tượng tiêu đề cũ lớn trong JavaScript,
chúng ta sẽ thấy chính xác nơi nó được lưu trữ một chút sau,
nhưng bây giờ >> Will Sentance: Có một cái cũ lớn
đối tượng tiêu đề trong JavaScript được gọi là object.prototype.
Chúng ta sẽ tìm hiểu thêm về điều đó một chút sau, nó đây.
Tôi nên làm nó với một màu sắc khác, thành thật.
Nhưng tôi sẽ, thay vào đó chỉ là, và
nó có một loạt các chức năng hữu ích sẽ có sẵn, thân mến.
Chúng sẽ có sẵn cho tất cả các đối tượng của chúng ta.
Nhưng bằng cách nào?
Bởi vì, này, bạn sẽ không tin đâu.
Nhưng tất cả các đối tượng trong JavaScript, không chỉ cách người dùng 1 và
người dùng 2, nơi chúng tôi đặt giá trị proto của mình,
tất cả các đối tượng trong JavaScript đều có thuộc tính proto.
Một cái mặc định, mặc định là liên kết đến, bạn có muốn đoán xem Matt ở đâu không?
>> Người nói 2: Đối tượng >> Câu nói Di chúc: Tới đối tượng này.prototype
vật.
Chắc tôi sẽ không vẽ mũi tên phải không?
Nhưng chúng ta hãy làm một ngôi sao nhỏ.
Các cửa hàng chức năng người dùng này sẽ liên kết xuống đối tượng này.
Đối tượng object.prototype, và bạn đặt cược vào đó là gì, Matt?
Bạn đặt cược vào chức năng nào trong đó?
>> Loa 2: hasOwnProperty.
>> Will Sentance: hasOwnProperty, anh ấy đúng chỗ,
hasOwnProperty, tôi đoán là siêu hữu ích.
Như vậy, khi tôi chạy user1.hasOwnProperty,
và thực hiện nó với điểm số như đối số của tôi.
Kayla, tôi tìm người dùng 1 ở đâu?
>> Diễn giả 3: Toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Trong toàn cầu, tôi sẽ tìm thấy nó?
Vâng.
Sau đó, tôi tìm hasOwnProperty trên đối tượng đó.
Tôi có tìm thấy nó trên người dùng 1 không?
>> Người nói 3: Không.
>> Will Sentance: Chắc chắn là không, không phải ở đó.
Tôi có hoảng sợ không?
Bản chất nguyên mẫu của JavaScript ở đâu có nghĩa là trình thông dịch sẽ đi và
nhìn tiếp theo, lên đến?
>> Người thuyết trình 3: Chức năng người dùng- >> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời,
có thể hasOwnProperty đang ở đây.
Là gia số, là Không.
Chúng ta có hoảng sợ không?
Không, chúng ta đi tìm xem, chúng ta sẽ xem xét tài sản ẩn nào, Kayla?
>> Loa 3: Nguyên mẫu.
>> Will Sentance: Thuộc tính proto, vâng, vâng.
Đừng lo lắng, chúng ta sẽ thấy sự khác biệt, nhưng thuộc tính proto, là một liên kết đến-
>> Người nói 3: Object.proto.
>> Will Sentance: Và chúng ta tìm thấy gì ở đó?
>> Loa 3: hasOwn.
>> Will Sentance: hasOwnProperty, và chúng tôi lấy mã của nó và chúng tôi thực thi nó.
Những gì chúng tôi thực sự đang làm với đối tượng của mình. Create là loại kiểm soát
về những gì chúng tôi đưa vào proto đó.
Bởi vì tất cả các đối tượng theo mặc định, proto của chúng,
ngay sau khi chúng được tạo sẽ nhận được một liên kết đến object.prototype.
Chúng tôi đã kiểm soát điều đó, nhưng đừng hoảng sợ, chúng tôi không mất quyền truy cập
cho những thứ này ở dưới đây, bởi vì nó là một chuỗi tất cả các con đường đi lên.
Đến mức tôi muốn hiển thị dòng,
để bạn biết đó là một chuỗi, phải không?
Đó là một chuỗi, >> Will Sentance: Đó là một chuỗi tất cả
cách dẫn đến tiêu đề của chúng tôi, Object.prototype.
Đối tượng này cũng có một thuộc tính proto.
Không, nhưng đừng hoảng sợ.
Bất cứ ai đoán được điều này là, tôi sẽ chỉ cho bạn biết phần đầu của chuỗi.
Điều này có thể có giá trị gì đối với proto?
Và?
>> Người nói 2: Đã nhập tịch.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, thực sự rất gần nhưng vô hiệu, vâng,
Nó giống như chúng ta đã hoàn thành bây giờ, không có thêm chuỗi, được không?
Nhưng tôi sẽ không đi vào vấn đề này chi tiết hơn, nhưng nếu bạn làm
muốn biết tất cả sự phức tạp của điều đó, hãy xem các phần cứng hướng đối tượng.
Thực sự [LAUGH] hoặc cuộc nói chuyện của mọi người về điều đó,
đi vào phần đó, chúng tôi đi vào chi tiết hơn nhiều.
Đặc biệt liên quan đến cách mảng và hàm cũng có một bộ sưu tập lớn
các chức năng được chia sẻ mà họ có thể sử dụng liên quan đến điều này.
Được rồi, còn một điều nữa tôi muốn nói đến.
Có, nếu bạn muốn xác nhận người dùng của chúng tôi có điểm thuộc tính thì sao?
Chúng ta có thể sử dụng phương thức hasOwnProperty.
Nhưng nó ở đâu?
Nó có trên người dùng 1 không?
Không. Tất cả chúng ta đều có thuộc tính proto theo mặc định
mặc định dẫn đến một đối tượng lớn, object.prototype,
đầy đủ các chức năng hữu ích.
Chúng tôi có thể truy cập nó thông qua thuộc tính proto của cửa hàng chức năng người dùng, chuỗi đi lên.